[Music]
and the Emmy goes to the co-hosts of the
real how does the sound of any winners I
[Music]
could tell you guys were in a little bit
of shock and you just I don't know we're
always the show that feels like we're
just working hard to prove ourselves so
tonight was a minute where like God just
took all controller we were the ones
just left like wait we're not having to
pretend share this with our fans you
know and when you think about the people
have won this award Oprah Ellen Kelly
Ripa how does that feel the talk okay
you guys don't get it we literally got
off the stage turn the corner and
huddled in a prayer and we were just
like very good God and so we're so
grateful and we will never ever forget
this moment in the way we feel right now
I know you guys don't actually Lonnie I
want to talk to you because you were so
overcome with emotion right there I mean
for lack of a better word and no pun
intended but it was real I mean it was
early out we worked so hard people don't
realize how hard it is and I'm thinking
about it getting emotional because all
we wanted to do was be given a chance
and people believed in us and like I
said it's our fans it's Fox is
Telepictures is so many people behind
this we it was just a total shock and no
surprise but it's a great surprise
you're the little train that could but
you did but you did
a little show that couldn't and we did
you guys told me on the carpet today
that if you won
you're not taking out your dress if
you're not changing your makeup for
tomorrow is that true
you see these little stack lashes right
now they might be changing by my
mustache but it's get me on tomorrow's
TV tomorrow
we're coming like this yeah we gonna
celebrate I was gonna say be honest huh
are you guys gonna turn up tonight and
the company is paying for it you went on
the stage fair I know I know but that
was like no but I will say when your
Emmy winner you can get away with
anything
[Music]
[Applause]